hello and welcome to this video NM
Tyrell and they have those NM titles now
I kind of think it's okay that they have
the CM because this is actually an
official video title and then hmm not
really i think this is kind of silly
because the those are completely am
different from country to country and
you have simply no way to compare yeah
what um what what what what what the
title like this is worth what check it
was weird anyway but he gives me that
piece okay I'm happy to check it yeah
this guy is from Jamaica by the way here
don't have that many many Jamaican
players they're more famous for and
track and field than four chairs but
then what the picture who's in bold
playing chess or items they want to make
it look like he was playing chest I
think that one was no they were there
was a king missing helpful for one side
which kind of gives a way that maybe mr.
board is not a very accomplished player
okay so let's see what happens here I'm
just going to wife 65 okay why not efore
was a good good piece let's lend some
support to it now can go King edge a
drug g8 maybe a piece up it's not that
bad
I def Torchic made something like that
would be cute
it's close just a night night that you
have to somehow if you protect scene
with the creed III yeah just go I
thought them quinta five would be good I
can also call 9725 so not not bad Queen
f5 night ages 6 wasn't totally sure it
neither five is also good on night to g6
bring the pieces around
son I'd f5 or that mention 96 it's both
good
what's a Bishop b5
so I don't see how he saves this f1 work
okay it's easy to play it if you appease
up
so please not some stupid check made
nigh g3 should win the Queen check
yeah that's the queen
Jim no it's too late
he says can i have a rematch please well
usually not tight was the design it's
five minute chess but um yea votes will
see anyway I want to look at the game
just real quickly it's a bit turn this
move was really a bit strange that he is
attacking there without having developed
stuff and I'm taking the center and tf1
the pawn many of white castles maybe he
can try to do something on my slightly
weird in king position but I can just do
this I think and plan tonight 24 it's
hard to believe that it should be
compensation and just essentially
bluntness the piece after that there's
not really that much to do I played
based on the strong night only for use
on pieces create five or so working and
some other stuff group takes a force
what the engine does that's kind of Cuba
checkmate in here can I have two wins
the house has also made yeah okay don't
need anything fancy so you can just chat
pick up stuff and win like that yet he
will ultimately let loose the Queen yeah
it came down to that piece blunder right
at the beginning ok guys thanks for
watching